[Applause]
alexander wills australia not a hard
thrower judge had that big home run
yesterday
high fly ball right field there it goes
sia in
a two-run home run for judge and the
yankees jump out to a lead that didn't
take long well michael baltimore is
coming off a four-game series against
toronto in which their pitching staff
just got obliterated it went just to the
right center field side of the
scoreboard so it got in
on a line drive home run
well all rise here comes the judge
another home run four and four days and
the yankees take an immediate
two-nothing lead with cole his worst
ending is his first inning and each
succeeding inning the batting average
goes down against so in other words if
you don't get him early he's going to
get stronger and the bases are loaded so
here is ramon urias 275 seven homers and
37 ribbies
and the payoff is a breaking ball cut on
him this only pushed his way out of it
as he struck out uris on a breaking ball
down
no runs one hit
and three left rizzo is on with one out
here is stanton two all
high fly ball deep right field going
back is santander cia
a home run for stanton a two-run blast
and the yankees lead four-nothing
well he didn't have to stop and deliver
a message to balaka so he got around the
bases a little quicker
[Applause]
six straight games now the yankees have
hit multiple home runs
and both this is a change up
stayed up a bit
i don't even think stanton really hit
this one all that well might have gone
underneath it but he doesn't have to get
all of it to get it out particularly in
camden yards giancarlo
no see
farlow and the yankees now take a four
nothing lead one and two on voight boyd
lined out to short in the first one
driven deep to left field fair ball it's
gone it is gone a long home run for
voight as the yanks go back to back and
they leave five nothing
well at this rate the oriole fans are
going to think the blue jays are still
in town well this one is crushed
breaking ball just says a spinner
right there for the taking voight does
not miss it
watch him look
as he hits it
he's coming right at you folks
voigt and stanton go back to back
and a belly to belly and the yankees
take a five-nothing lead so trey mancini
one at-bat he is out of the game it's
right abdominal soreness that has
knocked him out of this game
and dj taps one to anthony rizzo so here
is austin hayes
austin hayes swings and misses
looked like he chased one out of the
zone
hayes not feeling too good right now
either
here's kohl's 3-2
fastball striker yeah
you saw the pitch what could he be
thinking of so strikeout number five for
garrett five-nothing new york two outs
now runner at first seventh pitch of the
ad pack coming
and that ball is cracked a fair ball
inside the bag and with a boost from
first base balayka is gonna round third
and he will score easily
rbi double
for ryan mount castle rbi number 80
double number 23 in the orioles on the
board in the fifth well that's what i
was talking about you know get a hit he
makes a nice adjustment a little late on
the 3-1 fastball this one all over and
again the one thing that
every time we've seen him coming up in
spring training that the lake is going
to sprint
around the bases to make it five to one
he said ryan malcasso has bad speed the
orioles have first and second with two
men out so here's stewart who uh pinch
it for mancini and grounded out the
first that was in the fourth two balls
two strikes two outs pitch swing and a
miss chase the high fast fastball
strikeout number seven for call the
third inning that orioles have let off
placing a man on
chopper to second torres boots
and he can't even get anything
wow
so routine but not if you don't catch it
they moved him off a short stop two days
ago and this is what happens at second
well let's see how i mean it's routine i
mean the chef he just doesn't catch it
i mean you've got a 5-1 lead you are
looking for the lead runner now if you
double them up that's fine it never ever
happens if you don't catch it and then
of course the shell is just trying to i
mean he has to fast forward everything a
little bit 19th error of the season
committed by torres so first and second
nobody out
and the 3-2
up the middle and there's a double play
as
torres took it himself moving to third
is hayes and it's a 4-4-3 dp which they
really needed two down it was much
tougher than the previous one this ball
is scorched
[Applause]
waves off her shell makes the play
himself and then it's a double play
where's the 1-0 veleka hits a high fly
to left going back is stanton before he
hits the track he makes the catch to end
the
top of the eight five one yanks gallow
torres and urchella
[Applause]
like that
sia he's in the party 6-1 yankees
he came right in the door and got on the
dance floor that's right that's his
ninth with the yankees and his 34th home
run overall he homers to deep right
field on the centerfield sky to the high
scoreboard wall hey he's pal joey he
homers to right center and the yankees
take a 6-1 lead long-fat against
santander 6-1 yankees
and that one is ripped to deep right
field going back judge he makes the play
on the run took an extra base hit away
from santander one right fielder robs
another one
i'll tell you he's a
a well-rounded baseball player great arm
covers ground it's a nice running catch
and this year he's added stealing some
bases
it's unfair to be that big that agile i
mean he is a gold glove caliber right
fielder and michael king knows that it's
been the home run ball for the yankees
and they've used it to a great effect
they lead six to one against the orioles
first game of this three-game set
and that one is ripped down the left
field line
sia five home runs and it's seven
one yankees boy do they love
camden going yards
no visiting team has hit more home runs
at camden yards
than the new york yankees
379 of them now since camden yards is
open
[Applause]
two pitchers up and in
one down the middle and one into the
seats well look at that follow through
another double digit home run player
tenth of the year well the new pitcher
is going to be sal romano yesterday he
resigned with the yankees and here he is
he's back
gutierrez there you go that sneaks
through
and a wave around four wins
kelvin gutierrez keeps the ninth inning
going cedric mullins will bat it's a 7-2
game you know the other thing about you
know having good stuff and not
commanding it is
is the fact that and they're going to
come out and talk to romano is that you
get to see more pitches the more he
throws watch the hand right there well i
think he actually
i don't think he was trying i mean i
can't think for him but it looked to me
he was almost like worried that ball was
gonna hit him in the face so he's gonna
have to leave because you never know and
you lose all feeling in your fingers and
it's gonna be interesting to see how
chapman can switch it on because he was
not in the mindset of pitching in this
game at all and here he is in the game
with runners on first and second one out
one run in the 02
swing and a miss
use the splitter there and the orders
are down to their final out
swing and a miss and that will do it as
the yankees win seven to two
and they're stacking wins now as they go
two in a row after beating the twins and
now starting this three-game set and all
in all kenny a win is a win is a win